and check out this rumor i've heard tom
holland might be in it too
what it's a big maybe they're having a
hard time
getting him to sign off for this if they
could just get zendaya and tony revolori
to sign up then we could get a whole
crew gonna be a real sequel to spiderman
oh my gosh
guys the spiderman news just does
not stop never stops and let it keep
trickling in
why the hell not okay so this comes from
daniel rpk
daniel richtman uh we follow him on
patreon and uh you guys should too if
you want some latest scoops a lot of the
time
he is right especially in recent weeks
you've come to discover
i was writing about a lot of things a
long time ago sometimes he's wrong
but the important thing to capitalize on
is this could be true
so for spider-man 3 here we go there's
talks about willem dafoe they're
negotiating with him to join dane dehaan
we did hear about but also now
thomas hayden church as sandman
coming into it uh this is really cool to
me because i i like i have no idea what
the hell this movie is really going to
be
obviously some of these players have to
just be cameos
some of them might have actual integral
supporting roles maybe they're setting
up for some sinister six
be curious to know what your guys
thoughts are to me
i actually find willem dafoe to be one
of the greatest comic book villains that
is extremely
underrated his performance as green
goblin was just
so much fun chewing up the scenery but
also at times especially that mirror
scene when he's
like crawling on the floor he's willing
to be vulnerable and strange and weird
and thomas hayden church if they did not
have topher grace's venom which i'm
really hoping he does get rumored to be
in this tip
if that movie did not have topher
grace's venom i think we would have
really appreciated thomas hayden
church's performance in spider-man 3.
i actually thought he brought a lot of
gravitas to that role so if we get a
chance to honor
two villains who are pretty much
underrated because out of that trilogy
it seems doc ock gets the most praise
rightfully so he probably is the best
you know but out of that trilogy those
two villains i find very much
underappreciated so yeah i mean if they
have a chance to just
pop up on screen and go hey cool
you know i mean at this point i'll take
it because not everybody can be a huge
role and i
accept that um but i do feel like they
are really looking throughout their
catalog and just going
what worked that maybe didn't get the
chance to either have a button put on it
or
that just didn't have to end so we can
theoretically bring it back and the one
eyebrow razor for me
in this is norman osborne is is willem
dafoe just because of how
that character goes in the first
spider-man film but
it's a multiverse there's time travel in
the mcu there's a million possibilities
as to how he could be incorporated and
i think that for me personally i love
the father-son dynamic that they played
with in that first spider-man movie and
if they could even touch
back to that in some way with tobey
maguire i think that could be pretty
cool so i'm excited for both these guys
i mean it's
to me from everything we're hearing
about the warping of reality of how it
starts with one division goes into
spider-man and segways all the way into
doctor strange multiverse of madness
perhaps they really messed up reality
where even those who are dead are now
brought back to life
and then they're plotting together of
how to get their revenge or something
like that it has to be some like
major whatever cinematic crossover is
happening with spider-man 3 maybe all
the villains are like coming together
and he needs to team up with the other
spider-man to take him down yeah
yeah that might be a cool movie three
spider-man versus the sinister six but
all the six of them are from slightly
different worlds
pretty cool i mean if you're not getting
james franco to return
but you get dana hans to come in there
all right then
whatever this is i'm sure it's just
going to be a lot of eye candy i i feel
like even if it doesn't hit the mark
it's just going to be super fun and
exciting
regardless we might just be watching the
screen and love it the first time just
because of all the nostalgia that's
playing on the excitement of watching
them all
show up on screen together and then
suddenly we watch it a second time and
we're like
that wasn't really that good i mean
i don't think it'll be the case but i'm
like that's the way i'm like that's the
worst case scenario at this point is
that we'll probably still love it
regardless and then we go back and we're
like
actually i think it just played on my
nostalgia that's the worst case but i
trust what they got going on i'm excited
for this man this sounds great
also it gives you the opportunity to let
the villains of the trilogy shared the
same screen together because you didn't
get that before
you think of those actors all together
exactly you didn't get all that before
green goblin died doc off died and now
you can have a movie where all of them
are in the same
it's really this multiverse crossover
and resetting all the rules in the
process
and now my question is too it's been so
many years since they've all appeared on
screen they all look
older i can see how you have like an
older version of peter parker with tobey
maguire showing up on screen you don't
have to do any de-aging you could just
have him be like an older peter parker
why not
whereas if there's the death of like
green goblin
and doc ock if if you have these
characters returning
maybe being brought back from some
reality warping
thing wouldn't they have to still be the
same age would they have to do something
like de-aging to them or maybe doc ock
did live
that ending in spider-man 2 he does sink
to the bottom of the ocean
but like it's a comic movie he could
pretty probably be alive in some way
yeah and you know norman osborne got
stabbed through the thighs
so maybe he can come back with like a
darth maul lower half robotic thing or
something he just starts off where he
punches his fist out of the ground
yeah that's the first shot they buried
him in his green goblin costume
he just glides out of the car and then
it'll be perfect because finally at the
end
he can reunite with dane dehaan and dane
dehaan we never got to know his version
of norman osborne with chris cooper he
was
a background character so then you know
clearly james franco wasn't a
satisfactory son so maybe they'll be
able to live happily ever
after as two different osborne timelines
won
yeah i would find it interesting if they
did bring back
gwen stacy uh bryce dallas howard's
version from spiderman three
and if she interacted with emma stone i
think some people forget that gwen
stacy's in the
spiderman trilogy because she's such a
prominent character in the amazing
spider-man one and two and is such a
better character
that it's pretty easy to kind of forget
about oh yeah bryce dallas howard
was gwen stacy so it wouldn't be that
exciting but i think it'd be a fun
little easter egg to throw her in there
as well what if she shows up as
spider-gwen
oh
people want emma stone to be the one who
shows up at spider-gwen i think out of
anyone
that's good true she's going to come
back with her degrees
she went to school everything was fine
and in all seriousness i think we've
been wanting it but we haven't been
hearing
anything about tom hardy's venom showing
up here and maybe this isn't the film to
do it
i do think it'll be pretty funny though
if we did get
topher grace's venom to show up in here
just for one scene i
i come on we got anakin skywalker
showing back up in star wars you got all
these other players in here
you might as well just have him show up
for like one scene even if it's like the
post-credits scene and it's a joke
it'll be a joke work that's when tom
hardy finally shows up
and he's like wait a minute all right
now we gotta fight because what happened
to spiderman three wasn't he like put in
some weird dimension at the end or
something
like there was the explosion thing that
happened was hitting the poles and the
bells
yeah there's a sonic wave yeah there
could be something where it just shows
up
cool yeah just be a funny moment through
a thing and then yeah cause he like
falls down the
belfry or whatever right so he could
just fall through a portal into this
reality
yeah i think i think it would be
hilarious all right guys
well what do you think about this piece
of news leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click the
notification bell who else do you want
to appear in here
last but not least
daniel gallagher daniel my friend uh you
have been part of our patreon page
for such a long time tis the season to
celebrate with family and loved ones
and you are undoubtedly a part of the
reject nation
inner circle close friends family
because since we launched this patreon
you've pretty much stayed pledged the
entire
time you're an mvp and a lot of times
you might not even talk with us because
you're so busy doing your own thing
i bet you're not even watching some of
our content which is a okay as long as
you stay pledged
because that is the best christmas gift
we could ever ask for it all sincerity
dude it's been kind of a rough year for
a lot of people us included however
it's people like you with your
generosity that
help the holidays feel more like actual
holidays so thank you daniel for being a
part of our page for such a long time
merry christmas i hope you have a
wonderful new year and let me know your
new year's resolutions
in our patreon message thread that we
got going on love you buddy hope to talk
with you soon
[Music]
you